I wanted to talk a little bit about the
uh well actually the pair bonding thing
you know when you mentioned that I've
made a video that went viral called 10
reasons not to have sex before marriage
and um one of the reasons that I
mentioned in there was um
you know sex connects us you know so
during sex and it's not it's not the
same for men and women there's a really
interesting Ted Talk out there by a
woman that endorsed my book her name is
Don mazzler and it's called how your
brain falls in love and she talks about
how women release oxytocin when they
when they orgasm men do not release
oxytocin when we orgasm we release it
when we commit so if you think about
that the perfect time to exchange man
gives his last name woman gives her body
and the two people cleave together and
form a family unit and that'll get you
through all the storm's life but what
happens is for a woman if she gives up
the sex you know she basically transfers
the control because she has a lot of
control up until the point where she has
sex if a man is interested in hers is
what I try to help women understand is
that you have a lot of control in the
relationship up until you have sex the
moment that you have sex now you're
giving it to him because you're going to
be bonded to him and he's not bonded to
you yet so what now she's chasing him
around trying to get the commitment and
he's not in no rush because he's like
well you know he's already getting the
milk right why buy the cow so this is
what I try to help you know women
understand what but like you said if you
if you bond to somebody you know imagine
you'd get this oxytocin release and you
bond to this person and then you pull
away and then you do it again with
somebody else and then you pull away and
you do that enough times you're not so
sticky anymore and it becomes like you
said it's just very easy to dip at the
first sign of trouble correct
so um the tattoo thing that was what I
was going to ask about why do you think
tattoos are a red flag
look any woman that is obsessed with
drawing all over her body there's
something wrong with her I I've I've
never met a woman that's that's that's
heavily tattooed that didn't have
something wrong with her and that's just
not my experience that's been the
experience like I have a large community
with hundreds of men and beyond that
I've got a public Community with
hundreds of thousands of of followers
and the vast majority of them all agree
with that observation it's it's not me
making something up to uh you know paint
tatted up women negatively
um it's just not common men tattoos are
totally different I mean I notice that
you've got tats on your arms but it's a
masculine trait right like throughout
history men have tattooed themselves
it's you know it's a tribal sort of
experience for someone to write a
passage for some it has a lot to do with
culture and what they believe in
um but tattooing the female body hasn't
hasn't been as common as it is in modern
times
um and it's not that like it's not that
uncommon to see a beautiful woman
covered in tattoos and it's to me that's
the same thing as putting bumper
stickers all over a Lamborghini you just
don't do it it shows a lack of taste men
in my experience want debt free tattoo
free virgins that's what they want right
when a woman's tatted up it shows that
she's she's she's done something with
her past that isn't that particularly
favorable it's like you know when you
climb to the top of Mount Washington you
get a little bumper sticker and you put
it on your car this car's climbed the
top of Mount Washington that's what
these tattoos look like to most guys you
know it's like this guy this guy this
guy this guy this guy this guy because
realistically it's mostly guys you know
doing the tattoo work on their bodies
right and I know several tattoo artists
and the vast majority of them have
intimate experiences with these women
too at the same time
well I never thought about that
I was listening to some of what you're
saying about like the uh
you know virgins debt free and not
tattooed it's like you know I know
you've done some stuff with Andrew Tate
and um kind of reminds me of something I
heard from him say where basically men
want to be women's portal to the world
like we want to be the first one to show
them the world we want to take them to
the place for the first time the
restaurant the the country or whatever
and there's a lot of Truth in that like
you know when when when a woman has all
this experience you know you're not
showing her these things for the first
time and as a man you you want that so I
you know it rang true for me
um you ever get get scared of getting
canceled
not really I mean my life sorted I'm
sure at some point the woke mob's gonna
try to come out and try to cancel me
I've had people try to get me fired you
know which I thought was kind of funny
because I found it and I am still listed
as a CEO of my debt business and it's
like dumb people actually think that
they're going to file complaints it's
like my brother answer the phone and be
like you know he's the CEO here right
um but you can't really cancel somebody
that's anti-fragile right like they
tried to cancel Tate and he's even
bigger than what he was before right
most you know when you try to cut out
somebody's tongue all you really do is
prove them right so I think that we're I
think we're we could possibly be getting
to the end of this it seems like Elon
musk's you know moved to buy Twitter and
his move for more open speech and less
censorship
um it'll be interesting times in the
coming years because
um the the notion that you can cancel
somebody to shut them up hasn't hasn't
worked very well has it no not at all
you're right about Tate
yeah he's bigger he's bigger than he's
ever been I was thinking about that
yesterday I was watching something you
know one YouTube of his and I'm like if
anything they made him more famous I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out